es besteht gefahr für mensch und tier
das usutu virus hat deutschland im griff
und sorgt für den qualvollen tod von
amseln und anderen singvögel und zwar
massenweise und ja die gefahr ist da
denn die stechmücken die die vögel mit
dem virus infizieren können es auch auf
andere tiere und menschen übertragen
jetzt wird auch die bevölkerung um
mithilfe gebeten der aufruf jetzt bei
klicks um science-fiction täglich
wissenschaft gibt es bei uns abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er kein
video let's go herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vielen dank für diesen spannenden themen
vorschlag den er mir über whatsapp
geschickt habt zu meiner persönlichen
nummer für themenvorschläge und die
täglichen nachrichten an euch persönlich
von mir mit dem video link vorab findet
ihr in der video beschreibung benannt
ist das tropische usutu-virus nach einem
fluss im südlichen afrika wo es
ursprünglich herkommt stechmücken
übertragen das virus auf vögel und vor
allem amseln und andere singvögel sind
anfällig deswegen wird die erkrankung
auch als amselsterben bezeichnet ihre
leidensgeschichte ist schlimm die tiere
taumeln verdrehen den kopf werden
apathisch könne nicht mehr flüchten und
sterben innerhalb einiger tage das
fatale diese usutu infektionen können
weder behandelt noch verhindert werden
laut nabu also dem naturschutzbund gehen
die amsel zahlen in den ausbruchs
gebieten deutlich zurück und auch andere
tiere wie fledermäuse oder pferde können
sich infizieren
doch dazu gibt es laut dem bernhard
nocht institut für tropenmedizin in
hamburg kaum belastbare daten die
übertragung auf den menschen geschieht
ebenso über stechmücken passiert aber
eher zufällig die folge das sogenannte
usutu-virus mit fieber hautausschlägen
kopfschmerzen und symptomen selten kann
es auch zu gehirnentzündungen kommen
bislang wurden zwei infektionen entdeckt
die bei den betroffenen aber keine
erkrankung ausgelöst hat und doch fest
steht die personen hatten sich in
deutschland angesteckt denn sie hatten
vorher keine reisen unternommen dazu das
bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin eine infektion mit dem
usutu virus scheint also in deutschland
möglich ist aber noch keinen
grundversorger und wird im
blutspendezentrum gemeinsam mit
wissenschaftlichen institutionen weiter
beobachtet nach angaben des
naturschutzbundes deutschland nabu gab
es ende august also
28 08 2010 jedenfalls bereits 5000
meldungen mit mehr als 10.000 kranken
oder verendeten tieren darunter amseln
aber auch meisen haussperlinge und
andere arten und diese zahlen toppen
alles denn seit 2011 als diese art des
vogelsterben es das erste mal in
deutschland auftrat waren im spätsommer
immer wieder mal einige regionen des
landes betroffen vor allem aber wärmere
gebiete lang des rheintals und am
untermain seit 2016 hat sich das virus
dann über nordrhein-westfalen nach
norden und auch richtung bayern
ausgebreitet in diesem jahr sind vor
allem nürnberg bremen und hamburg
betroffen
zwar zum ersten mal dafür aber ganz
besonders schlimm dazu der nabu auf
seiner webseite ornithologen und
tropenmediziner konnten seit 2011
feststellen dass immer dann besonders
viele vögel verenden wenn das virus
erstmals in einer region auftritt wie
derzeit in nürnberg bremen und hamburg
in den folgejahren sinken die
todeszahlen sand auf ein niedrigeres
niveau
die experten und expertinnen gehen davon
aus dass vor allem der warme sommer die
ausbreitung des virus vorangetrieben hat
und die fachleute sind machtlos wenn die
todesfälle können nicht verhindert
werden bislang ist laut nabu noch nicht
das schlimmste zu befürchten eine
allgemeine gefährdung der amseln bzw
deren aussterben denn nach den
ausbrüchen gingen die zahlen langsam
wieder nach oben und haben sich
teilweise stabilisiert allerdings auf
einem niedrigeren niveau als vorher doch
lokal kann es tatsächlich sein dass die
vögel wegen des virus vorübergehend fast
komplett verschwinden
das einzige was zu tun bleibt die
auswirkungen der vogel krankheit genau
zu dokumentieren dazu hat der nabu jetzt
auch die bevölkerung aufgerufen
auf der webseite sollen kranke oder tote
amseln gemeldet werden wichtig dabei
genaue angaben zum fundort datum und
umständen so kann das ausbruchsgeschehen
genau verfolgt werden und neue ausbruchs
regionen identifiziert werden um das
virus besser zu verstehen können auch
fotos betroffener vögel helfen zudem
sollen verendete vögel zur untersuchung
ins labor geschickt werden
beispielsweise ins bernhard nocht
institut in hamburg benutzt dabei auf
jeden fall handschuhe oder eine
umgestülpte plastiktüte und vergesst das
händewaschen danach nicht denn wir
stehen alle in der verantwortung noch
gibt es in deutschland etwa doppelt so
viele vögel wie menschen doch nicht nur
solche infektionskrankheiten wie das usu
der virus lassen ihre zahlen immer
weiter sinken auch menschengemachte
faktoren wie etwa der klimawandel der
lebensraumverlust und das große insekten
sterben gefährten den vogelbestand enorm
und viren können immer mutieren und dann
kann es auch für menschen richtig
gefährlich werden wir bleiben dran wenn
er kein video zu solchen themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auch den
englischen klick zum kanal dafür einfach
hier draufklicken auch da gibt es die
ein oder andere video premiere
und da drunter geht es weiter mit
mystery auf wie alien mami revealed csu
stay tuned